[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another episode
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be addressing a massive
plot point in Harry Potter and that is
why on earth did Voldemort even want to
kill the Potters why would he go out of
his way to murder an unsuspecting family
that posed no immediate danger to him
the answer to this question lies inside
of the famous prophecy the prophecy of
course refers to the prophecy foretold
by Sybill Trelawney in Hogsmeade pub in
the year 1980 we know Sybil as the
professor of divination and Hogwarts and
we know that she has a track record of
successful predictions predicting at the
end of the 93-94 school year that
Pettigrew will escape and that Voldemort
would return however she was not always
so successful and in 1980 found herself
in Hogsmeade pub with Dumbledore
interviewing for her post as professor
while her track record was not good at
this time Dumbledore gave her a chance
because she was the great-granddaughter
of famous seer Cassandra Trelawney
during her interview a disappointed and
unimpressed Dumbledore began to lose
interest when suddenly civil entered a
trance in her trance Sybil spoke of the
famous prophecy that we all know
explaining that Voldemort would be
defeated it spoke of a boy that would be
born at the end of July that possessed
the power to defeat the Dark Lord
Himself what Dumbledore incivil did not
know was that Snape then a Death Eater
was eavesdropping at the door
placing Sybil in great danger from
Voldemort in an effort to protect her
Dumbledore hired her for the position at
Hogwarts the entire prophecy is as
follows the one with the power to
vanquish the Dark Lord approaches born
to those who have threats to fight him
born as the seventh month dies and the
Dark Lord will mark him as his equal but
he will have power the Dark Lord knows
not and either must die at the hand of
the other for neither can live while the
other survives the one with the power to
vanquish the Dark Lord will be born as
the seventh month dies what's
interesting about Snape eavesdropping is
that he did not hear the prophecy in its
entirety and only told Voldemort what he
remembered because of this he missed out
very important details like the fact
that Harry would be marked as his equal
and that he would possess unknown power
with this new information Voldemort came
to the conclusion that Harry Potter was
the boy the prophecy was talking about
early and James Potter was some of
Dumbledore's most powerful supporters
and integral members of the order of the
Phoenix which meant that Voldemort had
them on his radar Snape who hated James
Potter probably helped him with his
Intel as well the only other option for
a child that posed this threat to him
was Neville Longbottom who was born in
the 30th of July but Voldemort firmly
believed that it was Harry this brings
us to Voldemort snakes move
partially driven by ignorance and
partially by foolishness
Voldemort believes that he will be able
to circumvent the prophecy by murdering
Harry on Wednesday October 31st
Voldemort traveled to the town of
Godric's Hollow where the Potter family
lived it was here that Voldemort in an
attempt to murder Harry ended up
murdering James and Lily
Voldemort did not go there with the
intention of murdering Harry's parents
as to him there were no immediate threat
he had a very specific goal and that was
to kill Harry but thanks to Lily's act
of sacrificial protection Harry survived
and Voldemort's mutilated soul was
ripped from his destroyed body after his
killing curse rebounded back at him this
marked the end of the first Wizarding
war and secured Harry's reputation as
the Boy Who Lived
and that's all for this video please
remember to like the video if you
enjoyed it and leave your video
suggestions down below until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]